[Music]
[Applause]
ok ladies and gentlemen please welcome
the vice president of the United States
Al Gore
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. vice president we're very honored to
have you here and to have you as the
keynote of our first National Innovation
Summit and we particularly appreciate
the efforts you've made to get here and
flying in open overnight so thank you
very much for being with us
mit clearly is a an appropriate site for
this first council initiative on
innovation mit is clearly a national
treasure both as an educational
institution and as a generator of new
knowledge and of course it's
particularly appropriate since Chuck
vest is our Vice Chair of the net of the
Council on competitiveness representing
the academic institutions and I think as
you know mr. vice president this council
is a unique organization it's comprised
of business labor academia leaders of
America really working together to
improve our nation's competitiveness and
from the beginning we have recognized
that government has a key role in in
that as well and we have worked closely
with him and we're very pleased that the
Clinton administration really recognized
this from its beginnings and has worked
closely with us on that now what brings
us here today the members of the council
with the governors and the congressional
issues of both parties as well as
members of the administration is really
a shared belief that the competitive
challenges facing the United States have
changed and are changing a decade ago
the most pressing demands that faced
companies like Xerox and many of our
other companies were to reduce costs to
improve quality to shorten our product
life cycles and these really were the
survival issues of that time but we have
made significant progress on these
challenges we as a nation are
significantly more competitive than we
were a decade ago that is documented in
the council's a ten-year report on
competitiveness and we really I believe
have done this by working together with
business labor academia and a government
but we are now facing a world economy
that is changing very dramatically it's
becoming more integrated the information
revolution has open
new frontiers our competitive nations
have noticed our improvement and in fact
focused on our success and have focused
on improving their technology and their
innovation process and as President
Clinton and you have eloquently pointed
out it's a new economy in which is a
higher premium and than ever on
translating new ideas into new products
and services that will win in the global
markets and support high wages at home
ladies and gentlemen no one in public
life has taken a more visible role and
lead than the Vice President Gore in
trying to understand and respond to the
new forces at work his interest and
knowledge of technology and innovation
process I think it's well known to all
of us but I think many of us would be
surprised at the depth of his knowledge
and I've had this pointed out to me a
couple times both in the early days when
he was vice president-elect at the
economic summit in Little Rock but even
more clearly at one time with the
council that sponsored with the Library
of Congress a small conference on the
internet and the implications of the
internet and this was attended by a
number of CEOs a number of government
leaders and a number of technologists
and I know speaking for a number of CEOs
in the audience given the dialogue
between the technologists and the vice
president we all went home and said we
better get another tutorial on the
internet because he clearly knows a lot
more than we do about that mr. vice
president as you know we are discussing
in will discuss more today the ten-year
outlook for u.s. innovation and the
action steps that could position could
strengthen our position in this regard
and we are very fortunate that our
dialogue will be informed by your
perspective and of course we hope to
continue to engage you in a concerted
effort after this innovation conference
to strengthen our country and strengthen
our nation ladies and gentlemen the Vice
President Al Gore
thank you very much no please thank you
thank you very much thank you ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much for your
kindness and Paul thank you for your
very generous introduction
I've really enjoyed working with you
over the years and I want to say what a
personal debt I owe to Paul alaire for
being my tutor when I began the
reinventing government project for
President Clinton and he and a few
others came and gave me some lessons
that were absolutely invaluable in
getting that started and I want to
acknowledge the other leaders of of this
summit here this meeting Chuck vest is a
longtime friend and outstanding
president of this institution bill
hamberg chairman of the council and john
yochelson a President of the Council on
competitiveness George Fisher a chairman
and CEO of the Eastman Kodak I was just
looking at iridium latest project
progress yesterday from his former
company John Young the founder of the
council who's met with President Clinton
and me on so many occasions and serves
as a co-chair of the President's Council
on science and technology advisors and
Jack Shankman the vice chair of the
council representing the perspective of
labor and sandy Feldman who is is here
from the aft and a great friend and an
ally and also to the members of Congress
who were here I want to acknowledge my
friend Nancy Pelosi Vernon Ahlers and my
former colleagues on the Science and
Technology Committee Jim Sensenbrenner
and George Brown who I seen through the
lights here I see Jim and George is here
somewhere over here I served on the
House Science and Technology
committee for eight years and learned a
lot from these two gentlemen and we work
together to form a bipartisan support of
base of support for research and
development and measures to improve the
competitiveness of our country and it's
great to to see them here too governor
Zell Miller of Georgia and governor John
Engler of Michigan thank you too very
much
I'll have another of reference to
governor Miller in in a moment I want to
especially thank Dan Goldin who as you
heard from his presentation a moment ago
is a real visionary and he and I have
worked together since I presided over
his confirmation hearings when I was on
the Senate science subcommittee a part
of the Senate Commerce Committee and
back in the last administration and we
have had a wonderful working
relationship and he does a truly
outstanding job and I want to
acknowledge our former Secretary of
Defense bill Perry who's around here
somewhere and a great partner and friend
and there are all kinds of other
distinguished guests I probably ought to
to acknowledge but I don't know to to do
it without accidentally missing people
so I'll just go right on to what I have
to say here and I'd like to start that
by telling you what a pleasure it is to
be back with the Council on
competitiveness and it's great to be
back here at MIT I haven't spoken here
in almost two years it'll be two years
ago June when I was asked to give the
commencement address I really enjoyed
that and I told the story at that time
about a great tragedy that occurred when
the founder of MIT after 20 years after
his retirement came back in 1882 to
deliver the commencement address and
it's a true story right in the middle of
his speech he dropped dead now you see
you're laughing but as terrible as that
is I was I noted then I was comforted by
the fact that no matter how I performed
I would
be remembered as only the second
stiffest speaker in the history of those
commencement addresses and I can't I
can't get away from that I you know the
Academy Awards are coming up and the
Good Will Hunting which takes place at
MIT is among the nominees anyway last
year when they had the Academy Awards it
made a real impression on me because my
wife tipper and I were propped up on
pillows in the bed watching the telecast
and Billy Crystal the host came out with
to start the show with a an Oscar on the
podium and he mentioned that there were
so many people nominated and only a few
would win he cautioned them against
disappointment and he looked right into
the camera and he said remember the only
person who's guaranteed to wake up
tomorrow morning with a statue is tipper
gore
[Laughter]
as Groucho Marx once said I resemble
that remark anyway I'm very grateful to
this Council on competitiveness for
convening this critical national summit
and very grateful for the important work
you have done for so long and especially
during this past year because you've
been helping us understand the dramatic
changes that are taking place throughout
our economy and throughout our society
not only in the United States but
throughout the world and as someone with
a longtime interest in innovation and
it's considerable economic benefits I
have followed the work of this council
since its founding a dozen years ago you
all came back when others were in your
positions now and testified before our
House Science and Technology Committee
and Jim and George and I had
interchanges back then you've shaped
policy for a long time
I remember in chairing the Senate
science subcommittee we frequently had
testimony from this council and over the
years like water on stone you have worn
away some of the resistance you
encountered at first and we've still got
a ways to go as a nation as you continue
to point out very forcefully but we are
making some changes and under President
Clinton's leadership we've seen some
pretty significant changes but the
fundamental reality remains our economy
is now driven by innovation and as
Michel Porter's that talk and study
pointed out other nations are really
moving rapidly to take advantage of the
new ability to innovate that is out
there we are obviously at the dawn of a
true innovation age it's almost a cliche
to point out the sequence from
agriculture to industry to information
but the change is accelerating
consider these facts it's estimated that
the entire store of human knowledge now
doubles every five years for example
we're just a few years away from the
complete sequencing of the human genome
giving us for the very first time a kind
of instruction manual for the human body
when that human genome is completed it
will have a gestalt effect the whole
will be considerably larger and more
important than the sum of its parts
just as the internet when it was
completed to the point where everyone
could connect into it acquired a
significance far larger than the
incremental advance that completed the
last accessibility in the same way we're
going to see a whole revolution in
genetics and biotechnology even beyond
what is going on right now when the
human genome is finally completed and
it's so it's so close within a couple of
years microchips will routinely contain
1 billion transistors per chip the size
of a fingernail and the patterns etched
onto them will be as complex and
complicated as the roadmap for the
entire planet
that's difficult to comprehend and the
implications are of course vast I
mentioned iridium from George's old
company within six months I think
they've got 42 satellites up now the
constellation of 66 would be rounded out
in early September they'll have a couple
of weeks of a shake out time by the end
of September this year it will be
possible to make a cell cellular
telephone call from any point on the
surface of this planet to any other
point on the surface of this planet and
soon after there will be multiple
competing systems offering the same
service within three years it will be
possible to receive four
any point on the surface of this planet
information flows of six-and-a-half
gigabits compared to like 36 million
bits necessary for faxes and pagers and
telephone service it will be possible to
get six and a half gigabits six and half
billion bits of information flowing down
remotely wireless to any place on the
surface of the earth what that means is
that access to the information
superhighway will be available from the
sands of the Kalahari from the top of
Mount Everest from any place on the
surface of the earth now what are the
implications obviously they're so vast
that it's impossible to predict what
that will happen nobody could predict
all of the changes that flowed from the
invention of the printing press and the
ubiquitous availability of information
to average citizens when books could be
printed when it's possible to have full
internet access for all of the five and
a half by then six almost six billion
people on on this planet the the
consequences are going to be really
staggering
we're on the verge of fulfilling a
vision outlined by Nathaniel Hawthorne
in the middle of the last century 15
years after the invention of the
Telegraph he wrote these words by means
of electricity the world of matter has
become a great nerve vibrating thousands
of miles in a breathless point of time
the round globe is a vast brain instinct
with intelligence often it's easy to
chart the exact benefits of a new
breakthrough to our health care to our
pocketbooks to our hard disk drives but
today I'd like to briefly talk about
innovation in a broader context and to
talk about innovation not merely as a
material goal but as an ethic a constant
concern a continuing focus for our
entire country so
of you as managers are familiar with the
the phrase learning organization some of
you manage toward that objective we as a
nation must be a learning nation we have
to put into place the infrastructure the
policies the programs and the habits
that enable us to continue innovating at
an accelerating rate mi t--'s motto mins
at Manas mind and hand sums up this
challenge true innovation encompasses
not only the labor of our hands but also
the labor of our minds increasingly of
course brain replaces brawn and if
American industry is to continue growing
and thriving and remaining competitive
we must be willing to think and act anew
to keep pushing the boundaries of
knowledge and discovery and to reshape
our economy by redefining the way we
view our world Thomas Kuhn wrote a
path-breaking study many years ago about
the way revolutions in thought occur all
of a sudden new observations new
findings about the world don't fit into
the old models that we're using and then
slowly these unexplainable observations
accumulate to the point where the old
model doesn't work anymore and then all
of a sudden someone comes up with an
innovative new pattern that explains the
UH the previously unexplainable and
produces a new vision into which all of
the information that was mysterious in
the past fits neatly at a few precious
moments in our history we see this occur
in a dramatic way more than five hundred
years ago a Columbus set sail and
obviously by discovering the new world
he gave us a new vision of Earth
Copernicus was 19 years old when
Columbus landed in the New World and
just a few years after that just a
couple of decades after that rather he
produced the new model explaining not
only the earth but its relationship to
the solar system in a new way a century
after Columbus Galileo first turned the
new instrument of the telescope toward
the sky and shattered centuries-old
notions about the mechanics of our solar
system and obviously the I mean I saw a
cartoon recently maybe it was in the
Wall Street Journal about with the
Columbus speaking to Queen Isabella and
saying and not only will we find spices
this will create 3,000 new jobs and I
you know I think sometimes we we sound
like that a little bit and for obvious
reasons but the discoveries coming out
of the Age of Exploration unleashed the
greatest explosion of trade and commerce
the the world had ever seen new lands
brought new ideas and the need for new
inventions Europe's contact with other
cultures and customs while not always
mutually positive stimulated new
thinking in the old world now half a
millennium after Columbus in our time we
broke free from the gravitational pull
of the earth with the Apollo program and
we went to explore the surface of the
Moon but in doing so we dramatically
change the way we viewed ourselves and
our own planet dan knows that in in my
office in the in the White House my
office is down the hall from the Oval
Office I I work in the famous square
office in the in the White House and on
the on the wall is a is a photograph of
the earth that was taken on December 7th
nineteen
72 by the very last Apollo mission to
the moon it is the most printed
photograph in the history of humankind
the people who keep up with those things
say the next closest photograph is not
even close I remember when the Apollo 8
mission first circled the moon before
Apollo 11 landed and the image of the
Earth from space had a dramatic impact
some people anticipated that the great
british astrophysicist Fred Hoyle
predicted in 1948 in these words once a
photograph of the Earth taken from
outside is available once the sheer
isolation of the earth becomes plain a
new idea as powerful as any in history
will be let loose of course it wasn't
until the Apollo missions exactly 20
years later that we found out the truth
of that prophecy like a child's first
glimpse of herself in a mirror those
photographs changed our own self-image
we saw a world that was not as vast or
expansive or incomprehensible as we had
thought but surprisingly smaller more
interconnected and more fragile the poet
Archibald MacLeish wrote of those images
to see the earth as we see it now small
and blue and beautiful in that eternal
silence where it floats is to see
ourselves as writers on the earth
together brothers on the bright
loveliness in the unending night
brothers who see now they are truly
brothers this new image this new way of
integrating knowledge shifted centuries
of human understanding and brought about
dramatic results certainly such a
quantum leap in our worldview does not
occur all that often but when it does it
sometimes
takes decades to know where the leap is
taking us and in that spirit it's not
that different from the work that many
of you do each and every day pushing the
ever-expanding boundaries of knowledge
and discovery creating and innovating
for the ultimate benefit of all of our
people at its heart what innovation
means is looking at the world in new and
different ways our challenge is to
create the right climate for that kind
of innovation both large and small and
to harness its enormous economic
potential for the 21st century you've
already come a long way and with help
from so many of you our nation is
building a new economy one that takes
innovation as its starting point not as
a mere byproduct the new economy is
driven by innovation information and
Technology are its fuels the new economy
values the productivity and creativity
of people above all else
yesterday I had long sessions in Silicon
Valley with the Prime Minister of Russia
Victor Turner Mirren and the CEOs of
many of the leading high technology
firms some of you all couldn't be there
because you were on your way here for
this for this meeting bill Perry was one
in that category bill Hambrick there's
some others but we had quite a
representation from the high tech
community there and they made it plain
to the leadership of Russia what we
already know which is that by far the
most valuable resource or asset that any
nation has is the unused creativity and
brainpower of the men and women in that
nation Russia has more PhDs per capita
than any nation on the face of this
earth you talk about an innovation
policy they need one and we do too and
there there are a lot of things that it
is now obvious with this new world view
we need to be doing right
now the new economy is connected to the
global marketplace where we zap dollars
and date around the world at the speed
of light now today we do have some
things going for us the American economy
is once again the envy of the world
interest rates and inflation are at
record lows investment and modernization
are both rising we have 15 million new
jobs the lowest unemployment in a
generation and today a full third of our
GDP growth now comes from information
technology our fast-growing
environmental technology industry is
already bigger than our steel industry
textile industry or aerospace industry
more Americans build semiconductors now
than construction machinery more
Americans spend their days processing
data than refining petroleum more
Americans now build computers than build
cars perhaps more importantly today
there is left less difference between
the task of building a computer and
building a car open up a car and it
doesn't look a lot different than some
computers today's Ford Taurus has more
computing power than those Apollo
spacecraft in the 1960s and 70s and
those that build cars do so in ways that
emphasize quality performance and
innovation part of what we used to call
and some still call the Japanese
challenge came about because they
figured out how to innovate new
generations of products like cars in a
much shorter period of time they they
took the lead time from the idea for a
new car from that point to the
appearance of the new car from seven
years down to five years down to three
years and there's a great race on now to
get that process down to one year some
of the technologies that Dan Goldin
referred to will be important in that
process already in the aircraft
manufacturing industry Boeing is leading
the entire world because it has figured
out how to use some of the new
information technologies
to compress that development period down
to the bare minimum the triple seven as
many of you know was created without any
paper to speak off completely in digital
form and the maintenance can be done
digitally as well their telescoping that
lead time from idea to the appearance of
the product really across the board and
our own automobile industries companies
are are now on the verge of creating the
largest most powerful extra net in in
the world to connect with their
suppliers and subcontractors and move
toward digital paperless information
flows in the development of new vehicles
we are working with the big three in the
partnership for a new generation of
vehicles to move beyond the internal
combustion engine toward a new
generation of vehicles that will have
much higher levels of efficiency will be
much more cost competitive with much
lower levels of pollution among the
other advantages now these two examples
illustrate the convergence of
technologies that is now giving us the
ability to get productivity gains from
computers long after their initial
introduction we know from history that
sometimes innovations are exciting and
obviously important but don't bring any
measurable improvements in productivity
for quite some time some of you are
familiar with the example of what
happened when new electric motors were
invented and introduced people thought
that they would bring improvements in
productivity but they didn't at least
not for a while why
cause the context into which they were
introduced had not changed in order to
accommodate the new potential the old
factories from the Industrial Age were
designed for steam engines and that
meant that many of them were highly
highly vertical with conveyor belts and
loops coming off the the central source
of power in the middle of the factory
when they retrofitted factories like
that with small electric motors the
inherent efficiencies in the electric
motors couldn't be seen anywhere but
over time that those physical plants
wore out new factories were built and
designed in a way that accommodated the
inherent efficiencies of that new
technology and so after a long delay all
of a sudden there was a surge in
productivity because the inherent
advantages were able to be expressed in
the new context that was created I think
we're seeing something exactly like that
now with the delayed productivity gains
from the introduction of micro
processors and computers and networks as
businesses and industries now redesign
their physical plants and more
importantly their processes and their
human interactions in ways that take
advantage of the new abilities conferred
by micro processing that's why I
sometimes wonder about the measurements
that are used on innovation and
productivity we have to make do with
what measurements so we can get our
hands on but this is inherently a very
inexact process and those of you who've
spent a long time studying productivity
know that it's
just the studies are just a mess they're
just so many factors involved and some
people will have great precision and
saying this or that about it and and we
again we have to work with the
information available but sometimes you
can introduce some new capacities that
you know are going to fuel a surge in
productivity even if it's not measured
for a while look at the Internet when we
started providing seed money in the
Congress more than 20 years ago for the
development of what is now the Internet
there was there was no enthusiasm in the
business community for it because it was
it was not relevant to the way business
operated at the time now of course every
business has its own web page and whole
industries are being redesigned in order
to take full advantage of the abilities
of the Internet when President Clinton
and I took office there were only 50
sites on the world wide web that hadn't
been that long ago just five little over
five years ago and now of course
millions and millions and the increase
is geometric it is some it is an example
of a new capacity a new way of linking
together a new convergence a new way of
seeing the world that after a delay
produces a surge of productivity in fact
if you think back on that example of the
electric motors what happened there was
when alternating current was invented it
made it made it possible to distribute
electricity over a much wider area and
and then it was possible with electric
motors to distribute the sources of
mechanical energy throughout the factory
and co-locate them precisely where each
machine needed the mechanical energy in
exactly that same
what the internet is making possible is
a new form of distributed intelligence
distributed knowledge distributed
information and all of the old
organizational structures which like
those vertical factories based on the
steam engines relied on a central
repository for knowledge with all the
decisions having to go to that central
place now the knowledge is distributed
widely and easily and geographic
boundaries are not as significant as
they once were Microsoft has a contract
in India for maintenance and service so
that when you call the number they may
take care of it in Seattle or without
knowing it you may be talking to someone
in in India over the internet and
receiving the information seamlessly as
if it was coming from Redmond Washington
and of course many of you here could
give similar examples but the point is
today's technology is allowing us to
unlock a much higher fraction of that
unused creativity among men and women
all over our nation and we're able to
reach out to those who in previous years
would have been left out of the world of
innovation now we never know where we
will find the person responsible for the
next intellectual breakthrough it could
be a janitor right here at MIT you can't
you can't ever tell some of you saw the
movie
there's simply no question that if we
want to make the most of the 21st
century and this new economy if we want
to achieve the full promise of American
business we have to do everything we can
to fuel new innovation and discovery
built partnerships that encourage
support and reward cutting-edge ideas
and keep our economy strong enough and
efficient enough to take advantage of
them as quickly as possible along with
my colleague
I've worked on initiatives to try to
take advantage of these new realities
the Small Business Innovation research
initiative the first legislation which
led to the internet the first funding
for the human genome project and the
rest and over the past five years under
President Clinton's leadership we have
done an enormous amount to encourage
innovation for a for a quarter of a
century the number of patent
applications for inventions by Americans
hovered between 60,000 and 70,000 per
year that was true for most of the 1980s
the past few years have seen that number
jump up to above 100,000 similarly we've
increased the number of patent awards by
50 percent from the early 1980s we plan
to seize that promise by continuing the
bold new economic strategy that we
believe is partly responsible for the
surge of strength in the new economy
eliminating the deficit opening up new
markets to our products and investing
more in education technology job
training and Environmental Protection
and other efforts which help to secure
our future on the first point we will
balance the budget and will we will do
it this year the budget the president
just proposed to Congress takes the
deficit that used to have 1100 that is
very important when you look at access
to credit it's an old story to describe
what it was like for companies to
compete in credit markets with the
800-pound gorilla that had to get 300
billion dollars a year or more in order
to finance the federal deficit so we
made tough choices based on hard numbers
and freed up hundreds of billions of
dollars in capital to finance private
investments including research and
development and one of the other reasons
for our emphasis on eliminating the
deficit is not only the competition in
credit markets but also the simple fact
that in this new economy we're not on
the gold standard we're on the
information standard and
we get a premium in world credit markets
and finance markets when they see that
the economy is being managed well
investment capital is flowing toward the
United States we're seeing an expression
of confidence all over the world in US
markets we need to go further and
increase the savings rate that's a very
complicated challenge as your council
has made clear over the years but we
must do our best to meet that challenge
now the second component of our economic
strategy after having a sound fiscal
policy is to keep on opening markets for
American products overseas ninety-six
percent of the consumers in the world
live in other countries
that's why we've signed more than 200
new trade agreements in the past few
years and we're pushing hard for the
authority to enter into yet more trade
agreements
we're also aggressively addressing
unfair trade practices by other nations
we're insisting upon the protection of
intellectual property rights I just had
lengthy discussions with Prime Minister
Chen Amir Dan over the last three days
for example on that point and we're
putting in place mechanisms to help to
address the concerns of at-risk workers
as we move ever farther into this global
marketplace the third part of our
economic strategy is making those
targeted investments in the future and
that means first and foremost
dramatically improving our K through 12
education system and that's why we're
after hiring a hundred thousand new
police officers to help bring the crime
rate down we're now proposing measures
to hire a hundred thousand new
high-quality teachers to reduce
classroom sizes that's why we're trying
to connect every single classroom and
library to the information superhighway
that's why we're trying to finance the
construction and renovation of crumbling
classrooms and school buildings all over
the United States that's why we're
pushing national standards for for math
and reading that's why we're setting
specific national goals that's why we're
calling for
voluntary national tests you can ask any
classroom of students whether or not
they study harder if they know the test
is coming up and the answer is of course
yes
well if we have tests against which we
can measure progress or the lack of
progress we're going to have an easier
time figuring out whether we're moving
in the right direction or whether we're
moving in the wrong direction we have to
invest in the improvements to our
education system
we've already freed up more money for
access to higher education than at any
time since the passage of the GI Bill
and we we are addressing the problems in
our job training system we've called as
part of the initial reinventing
government report we call for the
elimination of all of the various and
complicated job training programs and
the replacement all of them with a
voucher system - to really streamline
the job training marketplace I want to
say that I encourage every single one of
you to look closely at an innovation
that Governor Zell Miller has put in
place in Columbus Georgia called the
ipact mechanism that brings together
universities community leaders and the
business community to dramatically
change higher education in a technical
school format to produce highly relevant
sophisticated skills that are
immediately redeemable in the
marketplace it is the single most
innovative model that I have seen and of
course we took the HOPE scholarship
model from governor Miller now we're
stealing this from him we're trying to
give him credit for it like we did the
hope scholarships but I really encourage
you all to look at that now investing in
the future also means investing in
research and development that's why
we're proposing the 21st century
Research Fund to have the largest
increases by far in funding for the
National Science Foundation the National
Institutes of Health the National Cancer
Institute and our other research
institutions that we've ever had
in American history we believe that in
the innovation age basic research must
be financed by the people of this
country through the institutions of
self-government simply because of the
obvious reason that for-profit
enterprises because of competition are
necessarily going to have to focus on
research that has more immediate
applications and that's why we're
investing not just in targeted research
but also in the undirected research that
often yields the largest long-term gains
of course that it takes private-sector
investment as well and we have to
understand that even though there are
new efficiencies in research and
development with computational science
and the Internet the new advantages that
supercomputers give still the basic cost
for research and development are
increasing and so we've proposed an
extension of America's 2.2 billion
dollar research and experimentation Tax
Credit which is critical to our most
innovative industries and we're
encouraging other policies that free up
more funding for private research and
development now part of our strategy is
also to unshackle the dynamism of the
new economy by freeing it from the heavy
hand of old outdated obsolete government
practices I've referred a couple of
times to a reinventing government I'll
give you a couple of examples
we're fighting to streamline the patent
law and we've proposed to take the
patent office
and make it what we call a
performance-based organization to get
rid of the bureaucracy of the past the
red tape the regulations have a CEO have
performance measures have strict
accountability set it up as a
performance-based organization and let
it go we think by focusing on results
and giving increased flexibility to a
managers and making other specific
changes we can bring about the kind of
transformation in government
organizations that many of you have
brought about in your private companies
already we have reduced the size of the
federal government by 350,000 people in
the last five years it is now smaller in
size than it has been since 1961 the
first year of President John Kennedy's
administration and it's smaller as a
percentage of the workforce than it was
since before the New Deal we've
eliminated 200 outdated government
programs eliminated more than 16,000
pages of red tape saved 137 billion
dollars in the process but we need
further improvements in regulatory
reform and in legal reform we need to
advance rapidly by using these new
understandings and new techniques now
we're paying special attention to the
growth and development of the Internet
we believe that the new economy is in
many ways an internet economy we have an
aggressive strategy to foster electronic
commerce trade and commerce on the
Internet are now tripling every year and
in just a few years we will be
generating hundreds of billions of
dollars in the sales of goods and
services we want to ensure the
establishment of an environment in which
electronic commerce can grow and
flourish so that every computer can be a
window open to every business large and
small everywhere in the world that means
minimal government no new taxes and no
cumbersome regulation that's why we're
working to make the internet a global
free trade zone to take advantage of its
full potential for stimulating
prosperity and our 21st century research
fund invests hundreds of millions of
dollars to help speed up the development
of the next generation internet which
will have data flows more than a
thousand times greater than the present
Internet and soon after that we will
increase it by another thousand fault
just imagine what the next generation
can help us achieve with data moving a
thousand times faster and having that
wireless access all over the globe just
three years from now I believe this
overall approach is one that will
definitely improve America's future
competitive
and I wish to give credit to this
council for generating many of the the
basic ideas upon which our strategy has
been based this dialogue you've been
having with our nation over the last
dozen years has really been paying off
and I encourage you to continue the kind
of forward thinking that you have been
up to before I close I'd like to say
that today I would want to issue a
specific challenge that I hope will
advance the discovery process and give
us a little bit richer understanding of
the world that we inhabit I referred at
the beginning of my speech to Columbus's
voyage according to historians a Spanish
sailor named rodrigo de Triana was
standing in the forecastle of the Pinta
Columbus's ship and was the first person
to see the new world today a clearer
view of our own world could help us
reach new heights of understanding and
that's why today I'm proposing that NASA
launched a satellite named Triana which
will provide the very first continuous
live images of the entire Earth from
space it will bring into the digital age
those remarkable pictures we received of
our earth a generation ago you know that
picture I referred to was taken 26 years
ago there hasn't been one since then
actually there was for a brief moment a
short video of the earth as the Galileo
spacecraft was speeding away from the
earth and it turned around and focused
it kept its cameras on the earth and for
just a few seconds we were able to see
for just a short time I should say when
it was speeded up that the film is very
short but then it was gone and the
reason we don't have any other pictures
is that images from Earth orbit even
from the geosynchronous orbit
2300 miles high just allows us to see a
tiny part of the Earth's surface the
angle interferes with our ability to see
the entire planet as you would from that
simulated view I'd like to show this
video illustrating the the idea behind
this satellite that I'm challenging NASA
to launch the first picture in this
video is the one that I described from
December of 1972 on the Apollo 17
mission you can see Antarctica at the
bottom it's the last picture we've had
of the earth except as I mentioned for
this brief stunning imagery as the
Galileo spacecraft left the earth
wouldn't it be nice to have that image
continuous live 24 hours a day we can
understand weather systems better if we
do now we'll be able to with this
project which will launch this small
satellite from the space shuttle bay
that's one of the options and then it
will be sped toward a point in space
between beyond the moon between the
earth and the Sun the Sun as you know is
96 million miles away 1 million miles
from the earth just shy of that there is
a point called the l1 point where the
gravitational fields of the Earth and
Sun cancel each other out and this
satellite can be positioned there to
focus a high-definition television
camera on the earth and send images down
to students by way of the internet we'll
be able to study the movement of weather
systems in a brand-new way understanding
our understanding of phenomena like El
Nino can be vastly improved if we can
see farther into the Pacific Ocean where
the storms develop this is a this is a
imagery that is very difficult to piece
together from the current weather
satellites this that's digitally
stitched together from a lot of
different geosynchronous weather
satellites it'll come down to three
university-based earth stations and then
made available worldwide through the
Internet and the launch will take place
in less than two years if this is
successful we will have live 24-hour a
day coverage of the earth within less
than two years I believe that this can
have tremendous scientific value and
help us to understand the emergence of
global weather patterns and help us in a
lot of other ways as Socrates said 2,500
years ago man must rise above the earth
to the top of the atmosphere and beyond
for only thus will he fully understand
the world in which he lived in different
words a former friend of some of us here
the astronaut rusty Schweickart once
described what he felt during the Apollo
series when he was orbiting the moon and
he said you realize that on that small
spot that little blue and white thing is
everything that matters to you all of
history and music and poetry and art and
war and death and birth and love tears
joy games all of it is on that little
spot out there that you can cover with
your thumb with triana that same
experience could be available to all of
us and as Columbus's reputed to have
said it will also produce 3,000 jobs
Daniel Boorstin the great former
librarian of Congress wrote the most
promising words ever written on the maps
of human knowledge are terra incognita
unknown territory that's true of our
ability to understand the earth our
effort to understand the new economy
it's true of your efforts to understand
how we can stimulate more innovation in
the United States of America I'm proud
to say that President Clinton and I are
ready and willing partners in the effort
to stimulate more innovation in the US
economy we will do everything we can to
keep
growth and innovation high and
productivity strong so let us continue
to blaze new paths to American
competitiveness continue to search for
uncharted territories be they near or
far and in the spirit of this great
institution let us apply our hands and
our minds and our hearts to that
endeavor for that is how we will build a
21st century and the new economy of our
dreams thank you very much
[Applause]